[Music]
you got to be a certain type of person
to get into flying without an engine in
fact what we're able to leave the ground
leave everything behind fly through the
skies on nylon and strings is
exceptional
[Music]
the rat-race is a 7 day long paragliding
competition with 200 participants that
also serves as the u.s. national
paraglide championship my name is Nick
Reese I'm a professional paraglider
pilot a paraglider race is very similar
to a sailboat race they race around
buoys we raise around several different
GPS coordinates that we have to hit
along the way each morning the race
course is determined by the weather for
that day and of course typically ranges
from 40 to 70 miles long the first
person to finish the course every day
gets a thousand points if someone's 5
seconds back they get nine ninety five
and so on and so forth and then at seven
days you add up all your scores together
and whoever has the most points wins I
[Music]
grew up in Long Island in a suburb close
to New York City I went to Beloit
College in Wisconsin and after that I
returned to Manhattan to take a job at a
PR firm my second day of work was
September 11th 2001 so I was walking to
work and I saw the first plane hit the
World Trade Center from the street I
don't know if that played a significant
role but it played some role in me
deciding that I needed to do something
sooner than later if I wasn't completely
satisfied with what I was doing so I
sold all my possessions I lived out of
my car all I did was fly I've dedicated
my life since 2001 to flying paragliders
for many years I've been one the top
pilots in the US and that to me is his
sign of success watching the start of a
paragliding race is a sight to behold a
hundred pilots launching off a hill and
then getting up into the starting
paddock which is what we call a gaggle
the start it can be a chaotic experience
of people that are trying to get to the
top so that they're in the best position
so everybody's jockeying for position
once that starts it's just a glorious
experience of you know rallying through
mountain ranges for a whole day with
your friends after seven days you're
pretty exhausted but you know that's
also the the real joy and doing any kind
of endurance event just like with
anything whether you're trading stocks
or riding bikes or flying paragliders
you're always trying to make progress
and increase your ability to succeed and
you know paraglide competition is a
beautiful example of pitting your skills
not only against your competitors but
against the elements
[Music]
I grew up in the family of skywriting
that's just a little kid that's all I
knew just like being an artist in the
sky I'm Greg Stennis and I own a company
called skytypers with my son Steven
Stennis
[Music]
my dad was one of the original sky
writers he started 1931 the one airplane
travels a big circle if he's gonna make
it no and that takes a lot of time to do
that and he decided hey there's got to
be a faster way to do this I'll just do
it with a bunch of airplanes and so he
came up with the method of skytyping
five airplanes flying in formation for
instance if we're gonna make an eye
everybody lets out just one puff there's
your eye if you want to turn that into
an L it's one puffin plus the bottom guy
lets out three more puffs
visually l this is a very specialized
form of flying
most of my pilot's have got a like ten
thousand flying hours so they're very
experienced you fly a a 5 B Tiger planes
when we fly it's roughly 45 minutes to
get up to altitude which is 10,000 feet
a typical skytyping message is 20
characters sometimes 25 and that's
roughly five miles length each letter is
the size of the Empire State moved 1200
feet tall there of the biggest ads in
the world and you can't miss them the
whole sky becomes your billboard
I do this because not only is it fun
because I love flying but I like the
accomplishment of what we do as people
we fly for and they're all through
we've gotten something like 120 years of
skywriting in the family
my dad trained me and I've trained my
son and I'm very proud about
[Music]
[Music]
the very first time I left the ground in
a general plane I knew it was over but
my life was done it's also gonna be
about two aeroplanes and it was not just
because I was in the air but I was
depending upon myself so my safety was
in my own hands it was one of the most
exhilarating sensations that I've ever
received in my life my name is George
Jacob and I'm known as gyro Jake that I
build gyroplanes from scratch what a
gyroplane is basically a hybrid airplane
helicopter but it's neither of the two
how many gyroplanes
I would say I'd built close to 20 I lost
count around 13 a few years back I
imagined what I want and what components
should fit together
then I machine out and weld up the parts
that are necessary to get the job
completed well sometimes you can take
two months sometimes it could take a
year there's times I look at it and I go
man I did that and it works and I want
to fly it when I first started it was a
pretty small clinic in Florida and so
we'd get together on the weekends today
the gyro community is probably increased
by a hundredfold especially with the new
revolution of the factory built gyros
the do-it-yourself builders are kind of
like the dinosaurs they're on their way
to being extinct there aren't many
people that spend most of the free time
building a gyroplane one after the other
after the other
there's no incentive like money that
compels me to do this it's just because
this is my pleasure this is my joy this
is my passion
a deviation high schoo we take all your
regular academic classes English social
studies physical education but then also
we have ground operations carburetors
Magneto's jet engines this airplane
behind me is my classroom every day I'm
on eccentric and I mustered an aviation
high school and I currently go to class
at JFK Airport aviation high school is a
public New York City High School
students evasion high school spend four
to five years working on repairing
airplanes and in the process they get
their licensing to work in industry from
the Federal Aviation Administration we
have a hangar on site in our main
building where we have 17 aircraft we've
been teaching students for 81 years to
work in the aviation industry
we're very proud to be the school that
certifies the most mechanics in the
country the responsibility of an
aircraft mechanic is huge I have to
ensure that every single bolt every
single screw every single piece of wire
is safely secured on that aircraft
prevent anything from happening while
it's in there
when we sign off any part it's basically
our signature that's allowing the
airplane to get into the sky and our
signature is worth gold we are letting
over a hundred people on the ground get
into the sky and get to the destination
I like working with my hands I like
getting out in the world I love seeing
the work that I put in flying there my
way of expressing myself has always been
physical my mom told me was like since I
was little it's like if I would be angry
or happy or whatever you would see it in
in my body language for me having a new
way of challenging my buddy a new way of
pushing the limits of my what my buddy
can do that was the thing that really
got me hooked in flying
my name is Inga Tito and I'm a dancer
and a world champion indoor skydiver
I started dancing when I was three years
old and as long as I remember I've been
dancing when indoor skydiving came along
I found something for the first time
that I was more passionate about than I
ever was about dancing suddenly I
realized like I've just found a new way
of dancing it's just on a different kind
of dance floor
the discipline that I compete in is
called freestyle but when I'm speaking
about my flying overall I prefer to use
the term air dancing because it's not
just about competing and that set
discipline it's about creating something
new exploring the limits of what we can
do in flying and I would like to take
flying from being a sport towards being
a form of performing arts flying for
sure is way harder than it looks like
the wind speeds can go up to 180 miles
an hour you have to be strong you have
to be flexible a lot of the body
positions look easy but they actually
require a lot to perform them nicely so
a split for example it might look like
I'm just resting in in that flexible
body position but I'm actually all the
time pushing against the airflow to have
control
[Music]
I don't always like the use of the word
talented because it makes it sounds like
only if you have that talent before you
even start flying you're gonna get good
I've always been like a hard worker
myself so if I really want to get good
at something I'm gonna do whatever it
takes it just depends on how much you
want it
you
[Music]
you
[Music]